the following is a presentation of the
st louis chess club
[Music]
welcome everybody to round six of the
2022 spring chess classic live from the
saint louis chess club i'm alejandro
ramirez here with grand master christian
carilla to bring you all of the action
of these two round robins christian
what have we had so far well first of
all alejandro always a pleasure to be
here with you in the studio commentating
on this amazing players we have players
ranging from the 2500 level all the way
to the 2700 level
those type of players that don't get
that many opportunities outside of the
u.s chess championships they're not
playing in the same field cup but we do
have these quarterly events that are
back here at the st louis chess club and
i'm very excited to see what these
players are going to bring to the table
absolutely it is an impressive
it's an impressive field that we have
here for you christian but it's not just
that i always love these tournaments
it's
a great way for these players to become
stronger to get money to travel to other
events to be able to fight against
players that are about their level and
try to distance themselves into that
elite pack of course these events are
not very common and i am very happy that
this quarterly events are back so
without further ado let's take a look at
what we have in the standings after five
rounds of chess we see a clear leader in
both groups and in the a group it's ray
robson after a very long round yesterday
against misha and people with the black
pieces he was able to score yet again
sits at four out of five but he's a very
closely pursued by ilya nishnik and
aranja kobianilia winning a nice game
yesterday while hakobian wow he just
defended survived by the skin of his
teeth against darius spirits yesterday
and sam savion sits
after her first first one of the
tournament on plus one three out of five
tied for fifth position we have jeffrey
sean darius virg enhanced neiman jeffrey
is coming from back to back losses with
the white pieces he's having a very
difficult event up to this point hans
niemann also falling by the sword of
camille dragoon who is in seoul eighth
position yesterday tied for ninth
position is misha antipov and alex
landerman who both lost yesterday and
only have scored one point up to this
point and what about the b group
alejandro it's your boy chris repcon
that's still making all the waves in
this tournament four and a half out of
five is such an impressive score he
finally was slowed down the gas pedal
there a bit he did make a draw yesterday
but still what a performance from repcon
he's followed closely not as closely as
in the group a but also closely by
christopher you anna bimanu mishra the
two youngsters of the tournament
remember that ami manu is only 13 years
old and he is currently on three and a
half points making a splash for himself
in this tournament with 50 percent we
have elsa maria de body and titus
tramavicius tied for sixth position we
have jj alimorandi
fun fact about these three they are all
representing different collegiate teams
one of them is slu one of them is texas
tech and the other one is ut rio grande
valley in ninth position we have robert
hungaski the top rated player in this
event unfortunately he cannot find
himself in this one he lost yesterday
and he only stands at one and a half out
of five in 10th position we have
harshida raja with one point
yeah he's not had the great greatest
tournament but he got a couple of draws
together and he will hopefully piece
back a comeback going into the second
half of the tournament we have
everything there in progress but let's
take a look at the format first it's two
ten player round robins on the time
control is classical chess 90 minutes or
40 moves you get another 30 second
uh increment from one and once you reach
mu 40 of course you get an extra 30
minutes of chess very important to note
the players may not mutually agree to a
draw in less than 40 moves that they can
find that elusive perpetual or
repetition but they cannot mutually
agree to a draw this is going to ensure
that we're going to see a very combative
event here at the st louis chess club
yes and let's take a look at the
schedule we have one round every single
day we have three rounds that will start
at 1 pm including the one that you
started earlier but the last round will
be at 11. this is to accommodate
playoffs if necessary we will be half a
match a playoff uh over the board if two
players or more tie for first place
although that doesn't seem to be the
case
right now we don't know how it might
change in the future and christian tell
us a little bit about our social media
well we love to hear from you guys so
get involved join the conversation you
can reach us on twitter at
spring chess classic also this show is
broadcast both on youtube and on twitch
and actually on twitch you can get
involved even further by donating
subscribing or donating bits tell us a
little bit about that alejandro how does
that help us for every 75 we get whether
it's through different subscribers
through one big donation whether we
accumulate the money for every 75
we are going to be able to put a kid
through the chess programming here at
the st louis chess club that's going to
help them become better chess players do
better at school it was the stepping
stone that goes from all the way from
scholastic chess up to the elite you're
going to be helping us with that for
every 75 that we get we have one child
in the entire semester covered that's
amazing and let's look at the pairings
alejandro let's see what we got in this
tournament in group a sam savion against
aaron jacobian definitely could have
been the game of the day if it wasn't
for perhaps even slightly more important
one there at the bottom of the field but
that's a big one alex slenderman is
playing as camin dragoon neither of
these players really being uh top of the
line in this event but still very
powerful contenders ilya nishnik is
playing as misha and tip of ilya is also
currently sitting in second place so
that's an important one to watch hans
neiman and jeffrey showing both players
and 50 trying to recover in this
tournament they have had a a good start
but a kind of topsy-turvy middle ground
there and they're trying not to fall too
far behind
meanwhile the game of the day certainly
has to be ray robson against dario
spirits both of them saint louis locals
darius attending st louis university and
ray robson
alum from webster university has decided
to stay here in the area and has been
living in saint louis for quite a while
they have a very solid approach to the
game right now we'll obviously be
getting into this uh a little bit later
but let's take a look at the b pairings
first christopher you is going to be
playing against raja harshit sao hanin
is playing against jj alimorandi even
though that game seems to be finishing
very soon
robert hungaski is playing against titus
stramavichus armen mikhailian will be
playing white against the youngest
youngest player in the competition
ambiva mishra and certainly the game of
the day has to involve this man chris
replica he's just been scintillating
over the board his four and a half score
catapults him to a very clear first
place and he just needs to protect that
lead he's a very ambitious young man and
certainly his chest shows that he's
going to be playing as one of the
veterans of group b
not as old as you would expect but it's
such a young field in group b when we
have two teenagers we have a bunch of
college kids it seems like being 35 at
these days in age and playing chess well
uh you're not you're no spring chicken
there but uh christian take us over some
of the highlights of what we have so far
in today's round well alejandro you're
definitely making me feel old but yes
let's continue with the analysis of this
very important clash between moradi
abadi and chris wrap up chris repka is
dominant in this event but right now
with the black pieces as you were
mentioning he's fighting against a very
experienced player that plays absolutely
everything he knows the ready type of
positions after knight to f3 g3 he plays
those he plays the english setups he
plays d4 as well
as well as e4 which was his decision in
this game and we've seen chris rebecca
win a crucial game earlier in the
tournament against uh hungaski in the
french defense but this time he decides
to go e5 he opens up with e5 knight to
f3 knight to c6 this is by the way one
of his main options so uh definitely
muradia badi was aware of what at least
he wants to do in this type of situation
a6 bishop to a4 knight to f6 and an
early d3 we know that castle is one of
the options as well chris repco
generally plays the open spanish with
knight takes e4 after d4 uh b5 bishop to
b3 d5 and so on we're not going to get
into those trenches but
it seems like muradiabadi decided to go
with d3 so that he can avoid the open
spanish the open spanish is considered
to be quite uh equal if black knows
exactly what to do and knows the
ramifications in that particular line d3
and now we see d6 c3 and g6
deciding uh to opt for this fianchetto
bishop on g7 rather than the typical
bishop to e7 interesting decision
definitely something that's still within
the books of theory g6
castle bishop to g7 rook to e1 castle h3
b5 and i still think this uh players are
within their theoretical knowledge a5
bishop to e3 a4 black is expanding on
this side and trying to take more and
more squares away from white's pieces
knight to d2 rook to e8 c4
challenging the pawn structure taking
advantage of the fact that i have a very
nice battery uh constructed by this
queen on d1 and the bishop on c2
attacking the pawn on a4 so you cannot
sidestep this attack with the move b4 i
like this move c4 by elshon we see
bishop to d7 by the way was played quite
quickly in less than a minute so
definitely uh chris still knew what he's
supposed to do in this type of
situations now you might be wondering
why not just simply take on b5 and take
an extra pawn well the problem is that
i'm going to go knight to b4 and right
now you cannot defend the pawn on a b5
and if you try to take another pawn well
that's a problem because i'm going to
take on d3 a very big weakness in
white's position the knight invades wise
position you have to move the rook so
that you don't lose the exchange but
then you lose a piece after knight to b2
this is big big problems for white so
instead of that he played a3 and now we
have this position
and at some point things went a bit
wrong for chris rapka for uh the leader
in the event after knight to d4 queen to
g5 it seems like this pawn is actually
finally going to fall and this is
exactly what happened of course you
don't want to take it immediately
because after bishop takes a4 queen
takes a4 well the knight on d2 is
hanging that's what the queen on g5 is
doing not only that it prepares an
attack against the king via knight to f4
coupled with the action of the queen on
g5 but also keeping an eye on the knight
on d2 so
instead of that white play the move
knight uh two f3 attacking the queen on
g5 queen to f6 bishop takes a4
and this is just a pawn i
simply don't see the compensation the
engine agrees with this assessment and
it seems like probably chris is not very
happy with the situation right now still
has some decent chances
nevertheless it seems like white just
simply solidified his pawn structure now
in order to open up and try to create
some counter play black has to make some
concessions that is opening up the king
with this move f5
it seems like white might be taking the
full point in this one and uh inflict in
the process the first defeat for chris
rapko well that would be a huge
change there in the standings but also
speaking of huge change let me see what
happened in this game between robert
hungaski and titus tarmovichus
oh you can see it on his face that is my
goodness that is actually what
it's kind of hard to understand what
he's missed and you can really see on
his face that he's understanding he's
blundered really really badly now let me
go to the key position a lot of things
happen in this game and honestly it was
quite fun but we have a 90-minute show i
really encourage you to go through the
game
if you want to enjoy it but basically we
got to this position where
black's bishop is just under attack he's
white to play the move a3 but let's
analyze the rest of the position it's
clear that black has a very strong
attack on the king side he has a queen
and a rook here it's going to be joined
very soon by rook a h8 and you can take
on h2 this is all good stuff
uh the bishop is hanging but tiger says
i don't really need to defend it you can
have this bishop if you feel like it
because if you take on b4 i take on h2
and
i'm not going to go and calculate every
variation but the computer i just turned
it on to make sure everything is correct
says there is no real defense against
queen takes g3 and rook h1 checkmate
you basically have to shed all of your
material
so hongoski doesn't take on b4 it's
poisoned instead plays the move bishop
f1 defends the pawn on h2 with the rook
and here a very simple winning move just
as an example would be to play the move
bishop c5 attack the pawn on e3
and remain with the threats that titus
executed in the game but he executed it
at literally the worst moment ever the
engine is actually saying that
this is completely winning for black and
it's not really a surprise right the
bishop on c5 is currently attacking this
pawn on e3 queen g3 is a threat it's not
like white has any extra material the
bishop makes a very bad impression and
what do you mean with queen g3 was the
threat well he could take on g3
immediately and the tactical
justification of this is that if you
take on g3 thank you for the queen i'll
be thank you i'll say thank you for the
checkmate
here and checkmate that's it that's the
end of the game so it seems like queen
g3 is brilliant
but it's actually a really really bad
move because after the move rook g2
uh i'm threatening to take your queen
with either the pawn or the rook it
actually doesn't matter because i
created a loft
if you take on h2
i'll take your queen it's the only move
but it's good enough this is no longer
checkmate because i can go through
f2 i will now play king g2 and run into
checkmate i'll go to f2
and if you retreat the queen
to that let's say h4
you don't have an immediate threat which
means that i can finally execute my own
of taking on b4
and that is just turning the game around
that is a disaster
that is an actual disaster disaster
because after queen to g3 and it's
it's very difficult to miss rook g2 like
i don't understand you have two moves in
the position three moves in the position
yeah you can go king to h1 and then the
queen on g3 is uh going to be
untouchable i can just simply go bishop
to c5 or bishop to e7 that's easy right
that's easy very easy to calculate you
have bishop to g2 which probably gets
checkmated after rook takes h2 or queen
hd or whatever
rook h2 is probably made easier and
queen h2 even stopped calculating so
there's only one move or you take on g3
right and yeah then you check two moves
right again and that's why he played
queen takes g3
but how did he miss rook to g2 like what
is the explanation behind this huge i
think the only explanation i can come up
with and here i am kind of uh guessing
it's as much guesswork as i can do is
that he forgot that rook g2 not only
attacks the queen but it actually gives
a flight square
and he thought that he still could play
rook age too
i have the feeling he completely forgot
that in this position the king has f2 he
he must have mentally thought
that king g2 is forced
and that's checkmate with rook h2h2 rook
8 to h2 checkmate but
he must have completely forgotten that
this exists and this is just a massive
probably the biggest blunder that we've
seen in the tournament so far because i
think this is the first blunder that
takes a game that goes from completely
winning
to completely lost
and that is
that is the cruelty of chess right i
just want to point out this important
fact alejandro because i was checking
how much time did he spend on this
sequence right it started off at this
point right because you are leaving the
bishop on pre with this move rook to h8
so you have to calculate a little bit
right bishop takes e4 is obviously an
option taking on b4 is an option
he spent more than 10 minutes on this
move
by itself after bishop to f1
instantaneously
he played quintex g3 he didn't he spent
maybe like 20 seconds right
unacceptable you cannot do that because
you are however sacrificing the full
queen you understand that he cannot take
it but you still need to stop think
assess reassess because at this point
there were so many ways in which white
could have played right to defend
against this rook takes h2 bishop to h1
is an option as well bishop to takes e4
is an option as well h4 isn't up
anything is an option right bishop to f1
included you cannot only spend 20
seconds on such a committal move and
that was just a practical mistake by uh
mavichus yeah a very big practical ex uh
mistake you would say a bit of an
inexperience even though these are young
very experienced also yeah
they are quite experienced yeah i mean
the strava vicious is chess at the at
the grand master level for forever he
was an iem longer than he should have
been he was one of those players that
was at 2 500 i am for a very long time
but
uh
he must be feeling terrible i mean
blundering like this
very unfortunately it's just
it's yeah there's no words
simply blundering the game away uh we do
have a couple of results well not a
couple we have one result so far uh sam
hanin has actually defeated uh jamiljan
ali marandi
and i think titus is like thinking about
resigning and thinking about what
is resignable it is complete
he did blunder a full piece it is it is
completely lost
there's not even any counter play for it
you didn't get any magic
there's no hook you can attack you're
going to have to play g5 g4 g3 but
before you get there i mean i'm just
going to uh put my extra piece into
motion and destroy you on the queen side
yeah big big setbacks there uh let's
finish up the b group because we're
already there and we already saw more
than half of it uh some hyenas i
mentioned did win against ali morandi uh
there was a kind of a strange game this
is the game between christopher you and
russia hardship it seems to be
very favorable for the black side if
nothing else because i do have an extra
pawn as black but more importantly i
think this king's a bit weak on f1 and
even though black is facing the pair of
bishops
i would definitely prefer to be on the
black side here i think 94 something
along those lines comes
and it's a two result game i don't know
how often you win this
as black i mean the bishops are kind of
powerful and bishop e5 is a threat
they are but after 94 that takes away
from that threat and the problem is
dilemma that you're facing as white is
that if you take on d4 obviously i'm
just going to take back with probably
the pawn actu actually right now i can
take with the queen you can think of the
queen because i think that you can take
back as you you promote one of the two
pawns i don't think that this might be
resignable this might actually be
already completely lost so you cannot
take on d4
yeah i think what do you do in that case
because my threat is quite clear i want
to take on e2 and check me yeah i think
if you take on e2
even though this gives the opposite
color bishop situation the problem is
queens are still on the board and in
many cases that means that uh well right
now is a threat because that's right and
right now it's a threat tactically right
if you take on e2 i cannot actually take
back with anything let me just make some
move to illustrate the point if you take
with the king it's checkmate in one with
queen d1 and if you take with the king
bishop d3 is a very simple pin
so knight takes e2 is a very strong
threat and i like the move knight d4 a
lot i think it's also extremely natural
so uh i give black a very strong
advantage in this position so how do you
defend after knight to d4 are you forced
to go bishop to d3 try to exchange a
pair of bishops yeah bishop d3 would be
among my first insects maybe king g2 is
okay uh just sidestepping the pin
because in this case i do ask you kind
of straight away uh do you want to go
into this and maybe some queen e5 will
force the trade of queens
i'm not saying that this will help quite
that much but i would at least put that
question on my opponent's plate i think
eg2 is by far the most logical move i'm
a little scared of moves like knight f5
for the knight hopping around uh it's
clear that black has excellent winning
chances in this position and i think
actually knight
f5 in that position yeah maybe just
finished the game quite good yeah so
yeah a lot of trouble there for uh
christopher yu
and in the final two games of this group
we have uh this absolute mess
between abimanu mishra and armand
mikhailian with the white pieces as you
can count it white is down a piece
now there's no answer to this bishop on
b7 but for that
uh they have a pawn and a checkmate on
two thread with the queen g3 queen g7
which can easily be sidestepped with
king to h8 right yeah this seems to be
the most natural move king hey then that
sidesteps queen g3 queen g7 because i
can just play rook g8 that being said a
second
problem arises in the position with the
move knight d6 and the main issue with
this is not only that i'm attacking the
bishop the rook and the pawn
but if i'd managed to defend this bishop
and the rook with rookie seven then
after knight takes b7 nobody's actually
defending the knight on d5
so
still it has to be considered i mean i
could play something like this but this
at this point i have the feeling that
white has enough compensation you have
so many pawns and your kings eternally
weakened so when i get to this position
i'm i'm wondering first if there's a way
to sidestep both threats and i still i'm
looking at rookie six
maybe just swipe that knight off of d6
when it lands there it's also not a
double attack and i think he just played
it
uh yeah i'm not surprised actually uh he
played rookie six
and i'm actually surprised that white
played uh this move so quickly what did
he play rook d4 i think it's rook d4
yeah yeah that didn't even cross my mind
he played it so fast he played so fast
like it was the only move that moved the
evening crossed my mind
uh
d4 okay
okay i mean it makes a lot of sense you
want to double up on the d file and
as soon as you double up you create some
immediate threats because you cannot
live with the knight either to b6 or c7
because rook d8 is just close to a
checkmate i'm actually warming up to
this move i don't know if it's a if it's
the best one i don't have an engine with
me but
yeah but it's a little bit move right
it's low
and it has an important lesson i think
that for everybody that's watching the
show and you're trying to build up your
attacks and you feel okay i'm down a
piece i really need to cash in i think a
very inexperienced move would be to play
the move knight d6 try to cash in as
quickly as possible but in many cases
the knight is fine on f5 it's a very
good attacking piece this bishop won't
join the defense anytime soon so because
the bishop is so far away leave your
knight in attacking square don't try to
cash in so quickly
improve your pieces
play rook d4 rook fd1 i like this
approach from white objectively i'm not
entirely sure if he has enough
compensation for a piece well how about
we just uh try to get ahead of the curve
and i'm not going to wait for you to
attack my knight i'm just going to leave
with that knight immediately knight to
e7 also trying to displace your uh very
strong piece the knight on f5 yeah 97
i'd rather like the only reason i wasn't
in love with the knight e7 was the move
knight d6 alejandra you weren't in love
with my move
i was not it happens once in a while
bishop c6 yeah bishop c6 and i was
trying to exploit the fact that i can
play f5 here
now if you take on e5 i have this nasty
double attack with queen g3 very nice
and if you take on d6 i feel that e both
both versions of taking on d6 should
give me
at least sufficient compensation and
with the move f5 now we understand why
the rook maybe is on d4 yeah because the
rook might be able to swing on the g
file and join the fray join the attack
yeah i like this move rook before yeah
this gets very dangerous very quickly i
didn't see the movie before at all but
once you put it on the board it's
actually more unpleasant practically
than it looks like and again i have some
feeling that the objective evaluation of
this is not good for white but
who cares about objectivity we have some
fun chess and the board is wide open and
nobody really knows what's going on i
like rook d4
i'm going to say it's a mess leave it at
that and move on and we did see the
replica game in which not a lot of
things have happened that's new uh white
still seems to be up upon for no real
compensation uh so let's move on to
group a
by by the way can we just stay on that
game for just a second to show you how
we got to that position i'm actually
curious because it's quite interesting
at least starting from this position
right so white is trying to expand in
the center black is trying to expand on
the queen side and you look at the
position your opponent just threatened
your bishop you start calculating right
you're thinking about okay i can take on
f6 you take i take and let's calculate
that position who knows uh how to assess
that sure you can go bishop to e2 just
retweet normal move you can go bishop to
e4 another normal move you can even take
on g6
right thank you actually yeah why didn't
you take on g you take on f6 then this
seems uh like quite a good position for
white you're an extra pawn of course
black has some compensation given up by
this very strong bishop on the long
diagonal coupled with the action of the
rooks with the majority on the queen
side it looks quite complicated right
after c4 he played the move bishop to f5
what i would never think of this move
this is the one of the funniest moves
i've seen in a very long while right
because it doesn't actually throw
anything it doesn't threaten anything
also it's a terrible move
it's a terrible move bishop to f5
to d5 and the position is already
winning for black in one move because i
have a couple of threats one of them is
to go knight to e3 that's going to be a
family fork uh no i like the style i
like the style i understand
understand the engine thinks it's
complete nonsense but okay most of our
chess is like that anyway
he believed in his conversing him into
taking this piece a free piece right and
now we have this position and basically
rookie six rook d4
mikhailian by the way seems to be very
happy with his decision so that also
helps yeah i like the confidence yep
yeah yeah objectivity in chess is
definitely overrated sometimes you have
to bring the confidence you have to
bring the attacks you have to bring the
fun and i am all for the move bishop f5
i would have never found it in a million
years
uh bishop g6 i think would have consumed
my entire the entirety of my time
but everybody has different styles okay
let's let's take a look at group a
uh this is the game between sam savion
and aram jacobian
i would say that winning is too strong
but
black is certainly in a huge amount of
difficulties if you count the material
uh this bishop is unopposed and has an
extra two pawns but black does have an
extra rook so it's an exchange
for two pawns
but more importantly they're connected
past pawns this one is a little bit weak
on e4 this is weak on g8 i have a nice
knight on e3 and the rooks have no
targets so it's really only white that
has a plan here and the plan is pretty
simple at some point you somehow
push pawns
maybe try to attack this one at some
point
and hope they promote and black is
maybe moved by move trying to survive
and i don't think this is very easy this
seems again i think calling it a winning
advantage might be too strong but i
would be tempted to call it something
close to that this reminds me of
yesterday's game between uh jeffrey sean
and uh who was it uh
yeah
right the same
imbalance in the position in exchange
for two pawns but two connected passers
two connected passes that's very
important and that looks very good i see
that you have the game uh nishnik and
tip of
any events there i i do yes so it seems
like nizhnik is slowly taking over this
position um
has arrived from some sort of a uh
hedgehog well it's hedgehog structures
right knight to f3 knight to f6 c4 c5
and then at some point we're going to
see d4 on the board and we have this
hedgehog structure with a6 e6 and then
d6 b6 slowly slowly building up the
position for black
and um
we got all the way up to let's say uh
this point where black decided to go
this move knight to e5 a very typical
way to defend against uh the threat of
taking on d6 of course you don't want to
defend with the move e5 because that
allows me to uh have full control in the
center on this uh square d5 very very
important square in the position and
this gives white a uh well almost
decisive advantage from a strategical
point of view so instead of that of
course black played the move knight to
e5 and now ilya decided to take on e5
now this gives the dark square bishop a
very important piece in white's uh in in
white's position nevertheless it also
allowed allows white to develop this
pawn majority on the queen side and
that's going to be the important factor
that gives him the advantage queen to e3
and now at some point we're going to see
the expansion breakthrough with the move
c5 which asks some immediate questions
how is black going to deal with this
tension on the queen side
so we have this position bishop to b6
knight takes a6 well that's a free pawn
it seems like rook to c8 knight to c5
i'm giving the pawn back but right now
the transition that happened uh
basically left me with an extra pawn on
the queen side because you have doubled
pawns on the e file this doesn't seem to
give you any particular advantage as
black and this apon is going to be a
monster
leading to what i believe is a very
serious at least practical advantage for
white in this position and tipoff is
going to have a difficult defense ahead
of himself yeah that's what it looks
like it's just an extra pawn up there in
the a file
do you think objectively
black is doing okay yes i i think so
because i have the engine in front of me
so the engine is saying that black is
doing more or less okay nevertheless
i'm looking at his time situation i'm
also looking at this a pawn and it's
just not looking encouraging right now
and i'm also looking at the body posture
right now look look at ilya seems
confident he always seems confident on
tip of not so much he seems kind of
worried about the position i mean i'd be
worried a little bit too uh
yeah the engine might draw it easily but
you kind of have the experience that
sometimes you really don't know what to
do with this apon and sometimes it ends
up being a queen and it's not a good
feeling
well we do have one of the winners so
far of today's round with us he has
defeated jj alimorandi and he's with
christian carrillo thank you very much
alejandro yes we are with a very happy
victor of today's round that is some
conning uh song first of all welcome to
the show welcome to st louis this is
your first time in st louis right yeah
hello
yeah this is my first time and i'm
really excited about being here so
it's it's a great tournament very well
organized so i'm happy to be here this
is also your first victory in this event
how does that feel no actually it was
the second second yeah it was the second
one
and actually it was the same opening so
i'm extremely happy with this speaking
of the opening let's take a look at the
game right now
where did you feel like you're taking
over
did you feel like you got an advantage
out of the opening or where did you feel
like you're taking over the game
actually
i mean it was uh my opponent was
prepared very well so it was like
the first line of engine so if you go
yeah h4 this interesting line of the sky
yeah it's very very interesting very
um double-edged yeah we're a double edge
very difficult to play for both sides
yeah and actually knight b6 is a great
move so
sometimes black may make a mistake on
taking g2 first so
but here your white is much better okay
yeah but knight b6 is good so be free
uh
yeah um castle yeah and here
were important moments of the first
line of engine is
queenie free and
if black take on d2
uh white take this with with the king in
his extremely double h position but
i felt that my my opponent is
is ready so i didn't really want to to
go for this crazy lines so i decided to
play more
more safely so i take on b4 yeah queenie
free and actually i don't
remember how exactly but
let's say f6 i was in game bishop d3 and
i was sure that
my
my preparation was like d5
um
ed
queen e3 yeah f e c d and there are some
like equal end game but
i liked it for for white because this
pawn on d6 is quite
might be quite unpleasant in some
but it's it's a good line for black
right yeah and i didn't know move fe so
i started to spend a lot of time and
it i might
it looks like you have some bishop they
say h7 knight g5 all those sorts of
tricks yeah actually there is i spent
most of my time because i didn't really
it was able to choose like between
knight g5 and bishop h7 because not so
clear what is better
yeah finally i decided to go with the
knight
yeah queen h6 decent move yeah here i
was like
not sure about this move but
i was kind of afraid taking this bishop
because
he just go go away and i didn't really
realize how i
uh
how planets because his next move is d5
and he starts to
um things are starting to become
extremely complicated right yeah king is
a bit shaky as well yeah and i didn't i
mean
i can
make a long castle but it's also it's
kind of dangerous and all of this
pins they are awesome
i wasn't sure about it i mean maybe
objectively white should be good but i
was a little bit afraid and my opponent
look
looked very confident here so
um i decided like to go for for an
engine it was actually it's also double
h end game because
um yeah here
knight g5
and actually i guess d5 is a mistake
but
so he probably is the best move
instead of d5 is rook f8
and i think that this is uh what the
confu the computer confirms
rook to f8 is the right move yeah
because
i'm not sure that i have
something better than than
the knight h7 so
yeah and here d5
also d5 looks natural yeah
but
yeah so he said bishop g6 is not the
best move yeah
so i don't worry about the engine too
much yeah
rook fade was played and it seemed like
the game was going through some
complications but this is where it was
fascinating right knight e6 c takes b3
and you don't take the rig you actually
go h6 which started a whole series of
of weird sequences yeah
yeah
actually
maybe it's much simpler just to take
rook on f8 but i wasn't
uh instead of h6 just take on a fade but
i wasn't sure about
b2
actually my opponent says that
he would play bishop c4 swords yeah
it could be become
like real double h yes
b takes a two coming b
yeah and actually i i have like five
minutes so
so it's
yeah even before age six uh doesn't
black have ideas of rook f1 maybe
he did he better yeah he played rook
four yeah yeah yeah yeah he's like was
in the game so
yeah
so h6 yeah rook f1 happened yeah
actually which is a bad move apparently
i'm not sure about rook fan but
yeah he should take on h6 yeah but i was
thinking that it's completely winning
for white because i take on h6
yeah
bishop a7
and then just a b
and i i was like
for that it's like
um looks like a domination because uh
i didn't see really how how play how to
play for black because
everything is hanging and
his skin starts to become
you know just bishop b5
try to get rid of that
it looks very scary for black though i
couldn't even castle right is that legal
i guess that's something one
unfortunately
bishop a1 bishop b1 right oh this is
awesome but maybe but i don't have a
threat
yeah but maybe it's better to play just
rook d1 instead oh sorry about that um
on b should be five oh sorry not on this
one
h6
and then it
takes on
h6
yeah
it takes
and just castle here
bishop b5 yeah maybe want rg1
but do you have a thread here what if i
just simply go rocate2
okay but then i have check yeah so
that's a check no wait i can't go back
to the gta take that's
that's a nice move yeah if it works i
don't know what it does
it doesn't have to go to e7 in that yeah
okay
i didn't see
didn't see this one it might not be the
end of the world right yeah maybe maybe
that's why
it's not so bad for black to take on h6
i'll just ask the engine and figure it
out actually long castles is the best
move
yeah yeah long castles is winning not
winning as plus one so
we i think we could spend here forever
and we completely lost such a difficult
end game to us right it's a difficult
end game but uh your opponent actually
played this clever resource
h6 rook f1 yeah i was actually happy to
see this move because i thought that i
calculated
pretty good but
maybe
maybe it's not so clear so yeah
fun yeah and probably here b2 is
it's definitely
yeah but this is a very strange move he
has to go to 95 right yeah knight g5
looks look decent and here i guess i
should find king g1 because if i say
king f2 he takes only two with rook and
i'm losing right
that's a big difference right
yeah so you have to play king g1 and the
engine still gives you a huge advantage
but it seems like your opponent made
your life a little bit easier with the
movie yeah after the
two no way that these pawns are
coming queen so
yeah now
my pawn on g7 is just too strong and now
this bishop h7 was a nice finish to the
game
and well so far kind of a topsy-turvy
game tournament for you sam how how
would you rate it
uh could you repeat please it's a it's
been up and down your tournament how
would you rate your own event oh i think
it
could be
would be better because to
[Music]
these two two games that i lost in a row
wasn't uh
one
would
would play for me but
but yeah it's it's still it's still a
very interesting tournament and uh it's
not so bad and definitely bouncing back
in you're still only in i am or did you
just finish your gm no i still need to
need one one one gm norm so
i am international master well it could
definitely be here uh the strength of a
grand master we don't doubt that thank
you for joining us here at the studio
and good luck in your remaining games
thank you now sam hanin they're winning
with the white pieces against jj ali
marandi i believe that it doesn't take
that many points to get a gm norm here
but it's hard to make them i think it is
on plus
three or two but i'll have to actually
make sure of that
and by the way alejandro yeah while we
were talking with sam cunning
we have alex lenderman who actually won
uh his game so we'll get back to with
alex in just a second yeah we will have
him in the studio real quick let's
quickly update if we have any other
results alex
erman has defeated camille dragoon
and in the other ones
um this one is the one that interests me
the most
that's a lot of pawns but rooks are
pretty active the only question here
really is if jeffrey has enough activity
to hold on to a draw uh bishop and three
pawns so you're going to get one of the
pawns right yeah you're going to get b2
and i assume you want to take it pretty
quickly well i'm not sure do i want to
give you my b pawn or my a pawn because
i can get my microphone all the way from
that i don't care what you think because
it's black to turn oh it's black soon
okay okay okay
but before we delve really deeply into
the angular action we can ask this
opinion we have a winner of today's
round alex lenderman defeating camille
dragoon
alex uh first of all congratulations on
your victory that is your first victory
of the event kind of a difficult event
for you up to this point what does this
victory mean for you
um well it's just nice to play a good
game
because
the first four games were really not
enjoyable for me like i was defending
every game the positions were not
enjoyable
so i decided yesterday to try to play
something more interesting
something new for me
um
okay it's even though i lost the game
okay it's more enjoyable game than the
previous ones so i wasn't that unhappy
because okay it's there are definitely
worse things right now happening in the
world than just losing a chess game
so yeah i was trying to go into the game
with a positive mindset like the four
round tournament completely from
from scratch
and uh yeah just focused on playing a
good game getting a position i was
relatively comfortable with and
going for a fight well let's uh look at
the game and see where do you feel like
you're taking over the initiative
because it felt like quite a balance
let's say opening phase of the game but
after that you at some point took uh
took full control of it i guess i was a
little bit surprised that he gave me the
d5 pawn okay it's uh i knew i had some
initiative
yes uh okay i was hoping that i have
some play on the king's side but okay
bishop c8 do you feel like he just
missed the rook takes d5 no of course he
it was a sacrifice i don't think it's a
blunder but i guess he thought that the
attack is very strong and he wanted to
go bishop five exchange the bishops and
uh
goku e6 queen g6 or something like that
but the problem with the move like
bishop c8 here is that when i take the
pawn on d5 i can easily go e4 and now my
problem bishop on c1 is not a problem
anymore i was a bit um
skeptical about my attack because sake
had a bad bishop on c1 so for that
reason i wasn't sure how good my attack
will be but i guess yeah he thought it
was going to be going to be very strong
but at the same time once i took the
pawn on d5 it just became so easy for me
to play
right
all right so it seemed that after this
is
it's not just about the pawn right it's
about the central control you got here
yeah yeah this and also activating my
bishop right on the c1 yeah it went from
c1 and now it's actually attacking the
pawns from being very good piece now all
of a sudden right so that's uh that was
very helpful so that forces the
transition into because for example for
example yesterday i also lost because i
had this bad bishop on c1 and i was
thinking oh no no not again but but then
he gave me the d5 pawn so i was kind of
happy at least i knew that i can play
this very safe position you also played
a bishop end game against hans neiman so
it seems like the bishops are definitely
a big uh playing a big role in this
story that was a much more unpleasant
end game i have to say than this one
although it turns out i was holding a
draw if i didn't step into that zoox
wing which i completely missed
yeah well alex uh congratulations on uh
this victory and we're looking forward
to seeing the rest of your games thank
you
thank you alex certainly uh always a
fighting player a very dangerous one and
it's good to see him chalk up a win
there in the event all right speaking of
those players let's take a look at the
rest of group a we actually haven't had
time to really talk about the matchup of
the day so let's jump into that it's ray
robson against dario schweitz
and it seems like a very balanced type
of position uh it's hard to evaluate it
you can see that both players are
gunning very clearly for different
things
white has put a ton of pieces on the
queen side and it's pretty much gearing
towards playing the move bishop takes d6
at some point and
opening up the position against the c8
rook now for the moment the c8 rock has
enough defense with this bish uh this
rook on e8 and the queen on f5 so if you
ever take
and i take
yes it's true that you might obtain
control over the c file but it's not
completely apparent what you gain from
it uh the c6
square is currently defended by the
bishop the rook doesn't do very much on
c7 and if you actually do nothing for
the remaining uh next
bunch of moves then after rook h8 takes
on g3 queen h5
black at some point will start
pretending that they have an attack on
the king side and that you actually
don't have an infinite amount of time on
the queen side so it's a difficult
position to play because
you're always calculating bishop takes
d6 you're not really sure when it works
and when it doesn't black certainly
doesn't want to release the tension he
wants to force white into taking on d6
so that he can remove this weakness from
c7
objectively it would seem my my first
impression is that this is about
balanced
it only it really does come down to the
fact of whether can i take on d6 and do
something immediate but with such a bad
bishop on f1
that's locked in by this pawn on b5 and
the constant pressure of h takes g3
that's the problem because
if i try to exchange that bishop well
all my light squares around the king are
going to become extremely painfully weak
yeah right and h3 queen f3 always comes
with a mating threat i don't want to
deal with that yeah it's the other issue
right it's a bad bishop but it's also a
bishop you can't exchange you're
actually saddled with it because you
need to keep it defending the light
squares that's a very good point
christian so it i think that darish is
okay here but i don't think he's doing
better than okay uh because the time
situation the usual
ray robson's actually
on 2 minutes and 20 seconds if i can
count correctly
is that is that actually true
yes
typical ray and then the irish has uh 8
minutes and 30 seconds so these time
time pressure maniacs are there bishop
d6 is fine how many moves do we have
left until we reach the time control uh
11 each
so
not exactly a small amount of moves now
the game might fizzle out quickly if
people start trading on c8 but
but then you have some weaknesses on the
queen side right yeah those pawns a4 and
b5 if we enter a bishop a light square
bishop end game well you might just be
completely lost yeah it's actually a
fair point christian you always have to
wonder uh which
pieces i can trade successfully which
ones i can't and it would seem
that
if everything comes off the board except
for the light squared bishops this pawn
name four is actually a very big
weakness and you lose a4 you actually do
lose the game they don't want to do that
um
i i have trouble believing that black
can ever really be better because it
feels that white is the one controlling
the flow of the exchanges i think he
went all the way and he did actually
take on c8 so i'm wondering
yeah he he take on c8
i doubt he takes twice
because if you take twice then black
gets the c file for free
uh but that being said why did he take i
thought he would go rook c6 or rook c7
well not rook c6 yeah i don't think you
can actually give up that exchange why
not
actually yeah that's a fair point
it's a it's a little risky right i'm not
so worried about something about that
there's something
he has no time to
calculate really do it but roxy stand
looks a lot more logical
the rook is a bit of a thorn
in um
in black side
and if you ever take it it's just a
better version of the game right because
of my rooks on the seventh rank i can
reinforce it with queen c3 if necessary
i am a little bit surprised by the
timing of bishop takes d6 and rook takes
it it felt like black white could have
done it at a better time
but also kind of understandable that of
what he's doing that being said the more
i look at the position there's some
pressure from the black yeah the more
i'm i'm finding it uncomfortable for
white and i'm not saying that just from
the bias
the bias point of view that that's my
student
um
but i am actually curious on what he's
going to do in this position we'll have
an answer soon as i see a couple of
those being played i believe it was rook
takes c8 right
rook takes a rook takes eight yes
rook takes c8 queen takes c8 and now
we're expecting some sort of maybe queen
to a3
i understand that this is probably still
equal but
but it feels like black is on the better
side of e it's much more equal for black
it's much more equal for black that's
how we like to say it it's more equal
for black than for white
um this looks
like ray is the one holding the defense
more than anything i don't know why this
was necessary like why any of this was
necessary first of all bishop d6 doesn't
see it doesn't seem like i'm taking on
g3 right now um and more and more
threatening to take on g3 potentially
and then go rook to h8 right but i
thought i could wait for it right can
you i don't know can i make some useful
move can i play queen c2 for example
sure
um queen to c2 but now the question
arises
all right let's take on g3 first so what
you can you cannot take on g3 first why
not
can you if i take on here are you take
back
you take here you take here and i don't
have queen takes correct because queen
f2 queen h2 is checkmate so i'm going to
just take back i don't want to take with
you can take on d6 still first and then
decide what you want to take yeah but
let's just take here i don't see the
problem sure but now can i go rook to h8
um
i don't think you can do this i think i
just take it right but i don't have a
checkmate though no this is a lot of
nice looking checks including queen h3
queen h2 or queen h5 queen h2 and then
you just simply go bishop g2 yeah bishop
my bishop chelsea bishop is so strong
yeah i think in a bishop is a very good
defender
i don't see how this bishop will trade
itself for this one so you don't really
have the time for do that i mean you
could do it a little slower and take on
a3
and then go rook h8
but even in the scenarios i'm not
entirely sure how you're going to be
making progress and at some point i'll
go rook c 3 rook takes c7 i don't i
don't know i mean it just felt like even
earlier i'm not saying that necessarily
in this position but even earlier when
this position was something like this
uh rare had the option of taking on d6
but i think he ran out of plans
and is currently on this position after
the move queen a3 23 looks fine
and i think the black is on the better
side of what should be a draw anyway to
be perfectly fair
absolutely all right uh what else do we
got well let's uh look at this important
game uh between moradia body and chris
repco because i don't think we've looked
at it in quite a while and a lot of
things have happened a lot of
simplifications in the position we left
it after this move f5 and i said that
sure black is trying to find some sort
of counter chances but at the same time
that weakens uh the king so let's see
where that took us it takes f5 g takes
f5 f4
rook to c5 queen to d3 rook to d5 queen
to e3
black is just simply first of all black
is a pawn down right and that's a big
problem not only that but black has a
weaker king black has a huge weakness on
f5 that i'm going to be able to target
and i also have a past pawn on the a
file that i'm going to be able to
utilize uh to convert my advantage in
the end game so
nothing points to the fact like black
might be able to survive this one rook
takes d5 rook takes d5 b4 c5 rook to e1
threatening all sorts of discovery
attacks with knight to c3 pointing at
the knight on e6 as well as the recon d5
he decides to defend that knight with
king to f7 and now we have this position
well to be honest after rook to d2 it
does seem like white is in pole position
to take a full point it has this very
nagging pin on the a to ga diagonal the
king is still weak
i do see this active rook i like this
for black look
black has one piece that is playing an
active role in this position and i think
this is all he can hope for at this
point so this one is looking good for
white nevertheless black still has an
active piece we're going to have to wait
and see how this one develops absolutely
no problems on either of these players
clock chris still has 11 minutes white
has more adiabatic four minutes and only
one move to make
and let's see what's happening in this
game between
uh christopher you and harshit raja
because it seems like horseshit just
simply took over and right now they made
the time control and i think harshit is
just completely winning we left it off
after this move knight to d4 yeah and
you are mentioning you're very attracted
to this movie it's very central it seems
like it's improving the position as much
as possible and we were looking at uh
the move bishop to d3
instead
white decided to go king to g2 and i
think we analyzed this yeah we thought
we thought f5 was crushing which it is
which it is and he played it knight f5
instantaneously
a very important moment after queen to
e5
this very precise move by black queen to
d8
not only that it supports the attack on
h4 this knight is defending the g7
square so there's no checkmate on this
diagonal this is crucial for the
position but also my queen is ready to
deliver the checkmate if i manage to
land the queen on h4 that queen is going
to drop back uh drop down to h2 and
that's just going to deliver the
checkmate so
i think he just missed this move queen
to d8 yeah
it's an easy move to miss i i would
assume queen to g6 is a much more
natural and then i can just simply
defend my pawn on h4 keep the two
bishops on
in play and the position is not as easy
right
but after queen to d8 which i do believe
christopher just simply missed
black is crushing black is completely
breaking through he's going to win
another pawn and the king is very close
to being checkmated queen to f4 was
followed by queen to e7 bishop to f1
knight takes h4 and i'm not 100 sure if
uh chris
for you has resigned or he's still
playing they've made the time control it
seems like they're still playing but
after taking on g3 knight to g6 you have
to defend against this queen to h4
coming right so the only square to do
that is a g4 but after that i'm just
invading with the the queen my king on
h7 is perfectly safe
this is over yeah this is just too much
it's the extra pawn and it's the extra
everything and queen e3 is coming we
need three finishes the game on the spot
if he finds it i mean he's going for it
yeah there's nothing else yup queen e3
very nice it seems like raja will be
getting his first full point of the game
of the tournament that kind of opens up
a fight for second place as
uh christopher ew is one of the leaders
uh outside of chris rapco no absolutely
christopher was on three and a half out
of five following closely behind chris
repco with chris rebecca potentially
losing yeah this is always really open
up all the tournaments because i'll be
mind you i don't think is winning either
anyway we'll we'll go back to that game
uh let's take a look we said we're being
told that we have a question from the
twitterverse uh let's take a look
uh a la
170 i'm not going to read all that so
much club is it really true that most
juniors are not as strong at end games
as other faces of the game some season
gms claim so if yes why hashtag spring
chess classic well thank you for your
question
let's get into it
my personal opinion is that this is
quite obvious
you can see it at the top level of chess
pretty much all the time and the reason
is simply because of experience
there are some end games that you can
teach and there are some end games that
the only way that you learn them is when
you lose them and then and then you kind
of build up this instinct on how to play
them uh a very clear example i was
talking to peters fiddler a couple of
days ago on the broadcast of the
belgrade grand prix
on how vidiq a very strong indian super
grand master well over 2700 was playing
this game against wesley so and in the
rook end game where peter thought okay
you must play this movie you must go for
the activity if you did actually sank i
thought for a long time and came up with
the wrong conclusion ended up losing a
game that he should have drawn easily so
this happens
i think at the highest level of chess
very often to young players where they
are not as familiar with the instinctive
handling of certain end games and it's
just a relative thing and it becomes
stronger and stronger the more they play
chess but to me this is
this is more or less normal yeah you you
build up a lot of end game experience
throughout your years that you can't
really teach christian you're your take
i i do agree with you and i want to
build up on that i think it's a clash
between generations because
right now the young players are mostly
training with the engines with their
computers uh actually not a lot of them
have trainers and i remember back in the
days when first of all the engines were
not as powerful you were forced to
analyze by yourself alongside your
trainer alongside your training partners
and games as well you were often getting
into that those end game situations and
you were spending a big portion of your
training time on those end games which
in return was giving you the necessary
skill the improved uh skill right now um
the players are definitely spending the
majority of their time in the opening
phase whenever they're preparing and i
just see this as a clash of generations
nevertheless of course once you reach a
certain uh point in your career once you
gather that experience that critical
experience that you were talking about
of course those endgame skills follow
i agree absolutely christian and
speaking of end games let's take a look
at a couple of them we have this game
between sam savion and kobayan aram
who survived really really by a miracle
yesterday against daryushan if he
survives today well that'll be the
second miracle in a row
because his position
is really bad and
here sam has an interesting practical
option
he could take on d8
and pick up the pawn on e4
but
trading rooks usually makes his life um
a little bit more difficult and he's
actually gone for the move rook takes d8
so
penetrating on the dark squares later on
is going to be actually pretty hard but
it is a lot of pawns i'm not entirely
sure if this is winning
or closer to a draw it's definitely not
going to be a fun defense for the black
side it might be objectively winning
but it's not so easy to see
the other option that he had is to
preserve the rooks go something like
check here on bishop c4
and make sure that this rook is able to
do a discovery on the next move
and preserve the
preserve the rooks on the board but
it's not clear that you're going to be
able to win the spawn on e4 so he takes
it right away the move g5 is on the
board and that certainly was a difficult
decision for mu 40 but he made it a move
41 so he must be very confident on
his analysis
i still think
this is closer to a win than a draw but
it's going to be a long one meanwhile
the game between hans demon and jeffrey
actually looks like it could have come
from the some sevien game a very similar
material balance but in this one what
only has two pawns for the exchange
and this one must be uh a complete draw
and i'm being told that they are
actually looking into a repetition after
the move rook c3 check
i don't think black's ever better either
no certainly not so this one seems like
it's just going to finish up in a draw
we're going to wait for the handshake
here
as hands i think could play king g2 and
claim the draw let me count it out
this is one
no no not not quite there yet but
um but i don't expect this to be a
decisive result either way uh speaking
of other end games let's take a look at
what's going on in this game between
misha antipov and ilya nizhnik
the spawn on a5 is still alive but no no
that's the pawn from e4
what that's the pawn from e4 no no i'm
in the a5 oh the blue 25 is still alive
which is a thorn on black's position
so misha actually calculated out to this
end game i i was a little scared about
exchanging so many pieces
but black said no problem it's all good
it's all good i got this under control
and he voluntarily went into this end
game which is actually uh let's be
honest quite terrifying because there's
a pawn here now luckily for black uh a6
actually just runs into knight b5 and
that stops the pawn
so the bishop needs to retreat and that
gives black just about enough time to
bring the king so let's show that on the
board a6 c7 a7 and here i would like to
put the bishop on this diagonal to win
the knight but i don't have a good entry
square because bishop a6
trying to do this
runs into rookie c6 and you're just on
time to play move away yeah one move
away and actually white ends up
laundering that a pawn and for that
reason he's played the move f4
sorry let me go back into the position
f4
trying to i guess open up the
the diagonal on king g1 so why did he
give up a pawn
well because he wants to uh
open up well first of all he wants to
avoid the king coming to d6
yeah this king doesn't have
the best route right now at least not
yet yeah because if you go through d7
maybe this bishop e4 move will cut you
off i guess
i have to contend with knight d5 but i
also don't have to hurry i can just
simply go king to f2 and try to focus my
attention on that pawn on f4 because
you still cannot uh touch that pawn on
a5 with the king right you cannot go
king to b5 that bishop on d3 is doing a
tremendous job of stopping you yeah it
is i agree it's very far away that being
said i don't know about decent games
right
right
but do i have to do that i can take on
h7 i think
that's another thing i was wondering
this kind of end games they're very
complicated because even though there's
a few only a few pieces left yeah
there's a lot of possibilities here even
taking on h7 might work so now that your
king is so far away i have this idea of
bishop to g8 yeah
yeah it feels like antipoa's still the
one trying to salvage some draw from
here it also feels though that he should
be able to there's so many pawns on the
king side right
so let's try to save that h pawn right
let's go h6 yeah
it feels like a very greedy move to play
h6 and give up a full tempo like that
but
it's a pawn it's a valuable pawn you can
imagine there'll be many scenarios in
which i just give up my knight for the a
pawn and i'll be thrilled
uh because i have more than enough pawns
on the king side to defend
but this all hinges on me being able to
take e5 so
king f2 something like f6 maybe
i don't know i don't really know how to
evaluate this end game
it's definitely dangerous for black but
how
dangerous because here i could play
bishop b4 maybe right
yeah bishop to e4
so you're trying to go bishop to b7 no
but yeah
then you go a6 i go knight b5 right yeah
that's another question right am i
actually promoting this pawn because the
moment you hit a6 i can go whoop knight
b5 knight a7 you still have a lot of
work to do that being said you're so far
away from everything can i go rook king
f3 and pretend yes but it's a lot of
pawns
so let's look at that
king to c7 yeah king c7 and i could even
consider this right
yes you can because if check if check
you can take on e5 and i cannot take on
b7 because of a7 i don't know if that's
true a7
a7 yeah yeah yeah so the game is over
the game is over it's a nice little
trick
so you cannot touch that bishop you can
never touch the bishop so you might as
well keep the knight somewhere right
let's go g5 yeah maybe it's time to push
push those spots here and then you just
keep pushing g4 or something
extremely complex end game to be honest
this is a three result end game no doubt
about it absolutely yeah i mean it
wouldn't be surprising that white's just
completely lost
so king g1 huh and this is the current
position what is the time situation oh
they made it the movie they just made
the time controls they just made the
time control so time to think
antipov is definitely pondering his next
move yeah and a critical move i think
it's a fun one i think it's a fun end
game oh yeah yeah
and alejandro let's take a look at what
happened in this game between mikhail
and mishra because you were mentioning
you were saying misra might not be
winning this one but if he does
that's going to be
four in a row
i think it's that's gonna be four years
four in a row for him if he wins yes if
he wins this one that's going to be four
in a row and he's going to be on four
and a half potentially catching up with
the leader chris repka so this is a
crucial game for the standings and we
left it off after this move knight xf5
rook to e6 rook to d4 this puzzling move
that uh mikhailian played
instantaneously and we were considering
king to h8 i think that was one of the
moves rook fd1 route to g8
and we see this position this transition
into this rook versus two pieces
situation with a weak king on h8 so
that's something that's encouraging for
a white for black excuse me but also
king to d8
rook takes d5 bishop takes d5 queen to
d4 and we see this transition black
still has an extra pawn take on b5 take
on b5 you cannot take on b5 because
after queen to e4 i'm going to have too
much pressure on this pawn on g2 your
king is quite weak and if you try to
defend with rook to d2 well you're
actually going to lose that rook with
queen to e1 so that's not a possibility
you cannot recover your last pawn so he
played a move rook to e1 queen to g5
and let's remember what mikhail did
yesterday in his game against chris
repka when he had the option of
exchanging the queens and entering into
a technical draw and he did not do that
he did not do that he allowed chris to
potentially build a decisive advantage
of course chris did not convert that but
still it was the wrong decision in this
type of situation a queen trade is
offered you're going to enter a rook end
game you have to assess that yesterday
he did not assess it correctly neither
he did today because right now he did
exchange on g5 and this is just
completely losing this leads to a
completely lost rook and game after rook
takes g5
rook to e7 rook to g3 this rook is going
to land on b3 which is going to paralyze
wise position you're going to have to
retreat with this rook on e2 i'm a pawn
up your rook is passive i'm just simply
going to build my uh
my position on the king side i'm going
to centralize my king and that's going
to be at the right moment i'm going to
create a pass pawn with b4 c3 and that's
going to be all she wrote it's a
technically winning end game he did not
understand that mikhail that is with the
white pieces and right now he's going to
suffer the consequences we have this
position on the board first of all i can
just win another pawn
i mean rook to g3 right
there's no reason to think more than
that this is over winning another pawn
i'm going to get this rook to g5 win
another pawn
what what a huge huge
huge moment for the standings that's
such a strange misunderstanding of the
positions you take on g5 take on g5 was
such a bad decision such a bad decision
and uh
well uh himself alongside his coaches
will have to reassess uh this uh this
type of situations where he's faced with
the transition into an endgame we had a
we had a twitter question earlier
exactly and this is your answer exactly
you see a lot of collegiate players play
endings
uh
i mean they they pretty bad actually
they're like
yes yeah
they're half strengths and weaknesses
all around
but i would say endgames is not their
strength uh has demons has drawn against
jeffrey shawn we had expected that for a
little bit
let's see what else we have
ray robson and darius we're still having
a long fight somehow this can go all the
way to the eighth somehow white is upon
up a lot of things happen this bishop on
b7 will actually never be good anymore
but
that being said this queen is coming to
b4
and when the queen comes to b4 i feel
black has enough counter play but at no
point will he be in a better position
this king is kind of weak i'm worried
about the move h5 i wish darius just
took on g3 earlier i'm not really sure
why he'd left upon an h4 forever
but still i believe within holding uh
sequence and this one
that's a lot of past pawns
but do you guarantee this is winning
i don't guarantee you're going to
guarantee anything
but i like uh wise chances i definitely
like wise chances yeah i feel that more
often than not you win this well first
of all winning no no i think this is
actually quite easy winning
really well you take on f4 right no no i
don't think i can take i think i have to
go king f if you think and i get my king
all the way to f4 and this pawn to g6
yeah yeah we we we stop arguing we agree
with this but are you playing f6 okay so
now i go king f3 i'm not going to take
on g5 yeah now i don't know do something
with the rook or shade or whatever
now i'm going to take on g5 let me take
on g5 and i take here
and now all i have to do is defend the
g4 pawn with my bishop
f5 this is actually very surprising but
apparently we're in table based
territory and it's winning and it's
winning yeah yeah just bishop f5 then i
bring my uh king on the other side of
the board which is going to force a
reaction from you you cannot stop my
pawns only with your rook so you have to
follow me with your king that's just
going to allow me to push my g pawn
which is going to be winning and king f6
has been played just out of curiosity
since we're already on the table base
uh this is actually a draw
because the king goes to f4
yeah you need to actually play king f3
first he's played king f3 i don't know
if he has a better move
let's say let's put the rook somewhere
else i don't think it will make a
difference right no i assume that i can
take and that's i'm doing my my plan is
very easy and this is a draw
are you kidding me no this is a draw
[Laughter]
you're
you're joking aren't you no no this is
straight up a draw the angel says this
is a draw so after bishop to f5 you go
rookie 8.
you go rook b4 and this holds
this makes no sense
i i understand that it makes no sense
but
it makes zero sense i mean computers
make it full of us all especially table
bases which we never really understand
the move rook d1 is on the board
the engine says
that actually loses because the only
move that wins in this position is the
move king e3
very clever move
no but he's never gonna play this move
no no because you see rookie one check
and you think why did i give up my pawn
on uh
on g4 right apparently you don't get
back in time this is actually winning
and you have to start i understand that
but
but uh this is not but there's nobody
that doesn't play bishop f5 right
correct but this is actually a draw
because you cut the king
and somehow you can make progress wow i
mean this is beyond human understanding
i guarantee you that you know even if we
brought fabi caron into the studio and
again he will not know why okay let's
try for an easier approach king to e2
first
uh instead of
taking on g5 yeah maybe k2 is an easier
way to do things uh much more practical
much more practical right rook uh d4 i
guess rook d4 king e3
yeah and this you could understand being
completely lost right the thing is you
go to b4 here once again we don't
understand anything
i guarantee you this end game is
okay rook to before i take on g5 i have
to take on g5 yeah yeah this is a drone
now it's a draw no now this is a draw
the moment that i can take on g5 is when
the moment the moment the engine tells
me oh look at that i have a table base
for those that don't know what a table
base is the computer at some point and
most persistence in chess thinks the
things about what to do it thinks about
the ramifications in table bases they
don't think it's just a database that
tells you hey these are all the
possibilities that can happen from this
position they're all masked out you
don't have to think anymore just consult
your database and okay so why
so why
there's no y yeah there's no y in table
basis no what will i this position is a
draw i don't know let's go to f5 let's
try to play
without the close your table base
alejandro i mean i can't right because
the moves that we make won't make any
sense
i mean here the move the best move is
king f6 i understand that the king wants
to go to e5 king d3 king d3 we want to
push these guys together this makes a
lot of sense
and we go king e5 that's fine that makes
sense right king c3 now we go king c3
kick out this rook
only move rook f4 that kind of makes
some sense even even though you one why
wonder why not to the b file well let's
cut the king here first all right b4 now
let's start pushing let's start pushing
pushing baby all right king d6
king d5 looks like makes sense too right
kd5 is the only move that makes sense
yeah king b3 b3 now i'm running c4
because it's a check you cannot take
because i'll have bishop e6 cure
and it says pretty much every move is a
draw
so like whatever let's play and even a
nonsensical move like rook f2 all right
let's push them check yeah yes and then
you go king uh every move is a draw are
you wow yes accept to c6
except to c6 after c6 that's actually
the move i would have made yeah any move
that doesn't involve king c6 is a draw
and i think the reason is that uh if you
move the king to c6 bishop b4 it gives
me a tempo and this poem gets to g6 uh
we do have a result as we expected uh
the rook swept those pawns on the king
side and mishra moves to a fourth in a
row in this tournament
impressive performance here by the
youngster
four and a half out of six so i feel i
feel we're embarrassing ourselves
christian but
it just shows to you how hard these end
games are
the move rook d1 is apparently a losing
blunder
and
trust me that none of us could explain
it to you without before the engines
came around and i think we're going to
see another resignation very soon in the
game between christopher you and raja
harshit because
well
one bishop is down for white no more
pair of bishops and
after queen takes c4
and the position we're looking at well
that's three points yeah that's three
pawns and that king
king on e3 is not really
uh very good position yeah queen c4
seems to finish the game that just picks
up too many guys okay you go queen to c7
right
yeah you make the attempt right you do
this you do this you say it's checkmate
unfortunately for white i do have an
important check on e6 it's the only
check but it's a good enough check the
king goes
let's go to d3 towards the or d2 let's
put it on d2 it feels a little safer
uh and now the only question is how do i
get back to defending queen e7 queen e7
defending absolutely everything 27 is
easy yeah yeah yeah once you see queen
you sound the game is over all right
that'll be that um
meanwhile what happened in the hangover
game
uh well white has a bishop i'm surprised
you still hasn't resigned but it's not
looking good yeah it's just a bishop all
right so so far we're looking at all
decisive games today in the big room
yes yeah because replica is going down
this seems
yeah this just looks totally lost after
knight h5 and queen b7 right
yep
yeah that's gonna start picking up the
knight it looks very decisive that looks
very decisive i'm sure that if you
retreat to e2 it's also winning but
uh you probably don't want to give them
any chances so that would we predict
rather harshi to beat christopher yu
uh
sam hanin has defeated jj ali morandi we
expect robert hungaski to defeat that
destroyer vichus
abbe manuevre has defeated armamelian
and we expect maria diaboli to take out
replica so five decisive results we
expect actually in group b it will be
the first day that we have either group
with such a scenario and that'll leave
us with group a
where we have already a couple of
results lenderman has defeated camilla
dragoon hans demon has drawn against
jeffrey shong
meanwhile
nishnik is still figuring out the ins
and outs of this complex end game
it's another one where it's extremely
complicated so we're gonna have to focus
on one
ray robson is apparently winning against
uh dario spheres maybe winning is a
strong word but certainly with the upper
hand i'm really really not sure why
he made the practical decision to give
up the h4 pawn
but here we are
it feels very unpleasant for black
because h5 is always going to be a
threat but maybe not so easy to make
progress as long as the queens are on
the board and it's not easy to trade
them either
so some some chances there for darius to
hold the draw but uh ray's trying to
look to improve his chances and then
this end game that we have absolutely no
clue about and we cannot figure out but
we think
no matter what the theoretical
prospects of this are
in a practical game
black loses this pretty much a hundred
percent of the time
white's plan is to push the pawns
and it's really hard to find the
absolute precise moves
that miraculously catch them or
miraculously block them well the problem
right now is that i'm also bringing my
pawn all the way to b5 so i have a
feeling that at some point you're going
to try to keep that rook uh on the b
file try to defend against any sort of
expansion but then just going to be able
to sacrifice the g4 pawn and bring my
king and that should be enough that
should be enough yeah and you probably
sacrificed it very slowly right you go
like
at some point you go king e3 bishop e2
and only when you put the pawn on c4
yeah and then you start running the king
yeah this looks this looks increasingly
hopeless i actually do don't i actually
think that the last few moves by sam are
relatively clever bishop d3 i liked um
there's so many scenarios in which a
bishop on e4 was a target
uh rookie won't make sense because
you're
cutting the king but
since i haven't taken on g5 yet your
king is still tethered to that side of
the board don't really have that option
of doing anything
so
it seems to me that sam7 is going
towards a second win in a row
and that's a big one that's a big one
for the standings sam is currently on
plus one around hakobian plus one plus
two and sam would actually leapfrog him
uh jumping two plus two himself and
around going down to minus one that's
all right number minus one plus one
sum is currently on three out of five
around on three and a half and sam will
reach four out of six
i think aram knows very well very much
so that he's lost
even if he doesn't know theoretically
that he's lost it you just don't give
yourself any hope of actually finding
the table-based defense of these no no
no no it it it seems like i was checking
it with
not sure about the table base but with
the engine and uh the engine was
recommending the idea of just stopping
the b pawn in its tracks with the move
rook to b8 so all the way
when we had this rook on d7 i think or
rook to d8 yeah just put the rook on b8
and stop this expansion with b4 b5
yeah it seems that uh this plan was
missed by
aram but again
a little bit
we could go back to the earlier thing
and say okay young players in their end
games but but you never figured this out
you just never figured this out rook v8
is actually a very difficult move to
play
so many years of chess knowledge and
experience tells you to put the rook
behind the pawns not in front of the
pawns and for some particular reason in
this one only the move rook bait was a
draw and we are neither strong enough to
figure out why nor do we have the desire
to be strong enough to figure out why
um
let's see what else do we have
uh but before we get into some more
games we do have a youngster that is
currently on four out of four from the
last four games certainly on a roll is
abhimanyu mishra the youngest grand
master in the world with christian
carrillo thank you alejandro yes we are
here indeed with avi manu i've been on
you first of all congratulations four
out of four what did you do after uh
that second round loss
yeah i mean i started to do more tactics
like i was able to like finish what i
was trying to do after that was like
finish my opening preparation before
that day itself after coming back from
the game and then just do like a like a
lot of tactics and that's helping a lot
because like they're like for example
this game against my first game which i
won in a row that my game gets raja this
queen v8 queen a7id like this queen 28
idea
i wasn't actually there was a similar
tactic that i was doing on some website
that i wasn't able to find this and that
definitely helped me after figuring the
tactic out to help me find this one in
the game and how did you deal with that
difficult moment psychologically what
did you tell yourself after that second
round loss or what did your coach uh
tell you sure
so i just told myself okay
loss has happened to everyone i mean
there's not a single person in the world
who has not come without a lot without a
loss and yeah i just they're so they're
i can't just ruin the whole tournament
just because of one game so let's just
keep playing and see how it goes well it
definitely worked out and today's game
was uh kind of wild he played this move
bishop to f5 at some point and we were
just completely shocked how did you
react to that move yeah bishop 5 i was
very confused about i was considering
bishopric's g6 and like h6 g6 e takes f6
and
it's very messy but i i'm honestly not
sure what's going on like rookie 6
there's f5
and i think yeah black is still under
some pressure here because rook takes f6
fg6
rook g6 there's rook d7
and yeah maybe maybe black is still fine
here after say rook g3 rook b7 but it's
not entirely clear but it's it's white
who has uh the much more pleasant
position
yeah
right well so bishop i5 was your initial
reaction
i was very confused i saw knight d5 did
you even consider bishop five before he
played it no not really
because i saw okay anyways i have this
knight d5 move so knight d5 and now it's
knight e3 is always a threat and he
played this queen f2 idea after after 95
queen f2 i think it's like with white
either you have to play queen after a
queen e2 because other than that 93 is a
third and gf5 so queen f2 gf5 knight of
five
and yeah i checked with him after the
game he said he missed the smooth rookie
six
right and the idea of rookie six is i'm
basically doing the same thing as king
of jade like
generally in this kind of situation kh8
is a much more logical move but after
khan knight d6 white white gets uh an
exchange back and it's
maybe black is still better somehow but
i really don't like it
yeah i don't think black's better yeah
yeah yeah so rookies is an important
resource but he found some kind of nice
moves rook before also yeah this was
very strange actually after rook d4 i
spent like 10 minutes but
maybe there's a win for black but i just
i just couldn't see it because i mean
rook d1 is coming next yeah and the
weird part is like i'm up a piece my
king isn't under immediate fire but the
thing is
he just piles up on this 95 and i but i
don't have a move i don't see how i can
defend it queen f3 93 was also possible
at some point yeah so we got to this
position and it felt that you took on d6
and yeah one play
it has an extra pawn but yeah still
not so clear right yes instead of rook
takes the instead of green xd6 i mean
during the game i consider knight f6
also
maybe it's somehow stronger objectively
but i really couldn't tell what was
going on after g4 yeah it's just a mess
because the main point of knight f6 is
after d7 you can uh i think you can take
d7
rook d7 rook g2
uh queen xg2 bishop six g2 rook takes
off seven
and now you have this place move bishop
d5 yeah
and if rookies d5 queen e1 queen e4
or kh2 queen f2 queen f3 whatever same
thing
but after yeah
and i but after g4 instead of d7 i just
couldn't tell what was going on for the
reason that like
my king is also extremely weak and d7
queen h4 is a very legitimate threat
and i saw like two moves here if queen
b3
there's king h2 and he defends this h3
pawn and if rookie's g4 d7 is waiting
for wyatt
and instead of queen v3 queen c5 which i
thought was
uh just because if black consolidates
here i think he is going to be winning
soon because 94 rook d8 if you you will
win this d6 pawn right but i was worried
about say d7 and say rogue deal queen h4
and
i just i couldn't tell what was going on
and like i had a few minutes before time
control like 10 moves to make so
i just chose not to go into this because
in the game i was
like in the game it's minimally it's
like not a winning advantage for black
but i'm
i have no risk at all were you surprised
by his decision to exchange the queens
yeah
after
yeah because i think he missed the
smooth rook g3
which was a great like yeah rookie 7
rook g3 and black is just like winning
because i bring back to b3 king comes to
g6 i play h5 h4 bring my king to f4 like
white is just tied down
like after king f2 i think black has
this nice move rook d3 right
all right you mean king f2 right now
yeah i can't do it
and if like rook b3 or rogue d3 i like
both of them are really great because
ideas i wrote d3 is that you cannot play
rook b7 because of book b3
king e2 is is impossible due to rook b3
again but also rook d2 right
yeah afterwards
yeah end of king e1 i can just like play
king g8 and
the thing is i kind of gain a tempo and
or maybe even h5 first
and by making sure that this king cannot
come in to defend b2 his rook is always
going to be tied down to the defensive
v2 pawn and yeah it's very difficult for
him to defend here if if it's possible i
think it's just lost is just a great
piece
on b3 is going to be doing everything
defending and attacking so
yeah certainly a bad concept there for
him but you must be feeling thrilled uh
there are four in a row uh great chances
to be actually tied for first place uh
going into the seventh round as we think
that uh chris rock is actually losing
his game uh did you feel that you had
good chances to win the tournament
before it started
yeah before the start of it i was this
was my goal to come here and try to win
this tournament whether it works or not
i wasn't exactly sure but i was just
trying my best to win this
well you certainly are on the way a nice
few games you put a strong there
together uh abi manu good luck in the
next few games thank you alejandro
all right let's take a look at what else
we have left uh we are expecting
resignation in a few games uh robert
hungaski has been down a piece against
uh sorry upper piece against the sermon
riches for the better part of an hour or
two
and that has not really changed
the game between roger harshit and
christopher u is still going on but only
in name only
i mean those are two connected free pass
pawns on g7 and h5
i really don't think you can stop those
no probably i just have to go
i like knight c8 uh defends the pawn
you don't need the knight for
okay i don't like this move
that's a strange move to put the knight
why not knight c6 knight c6 is a mirror
it is a very very strange uh
i mean then i don't see it is completely
controlled by this bishop it feels so
unnatural to do this even if i put my
pawn to a4 and a5 look he's probably
still winning it must be winning right
you go king here king here you push the
pawns you eventually hit the
then it's winning and i think it was a
strange move but his plan is is that you
cannot play the move a4 right now so i'm
i am going to put the knight on b6 in
the next move because right now i go
knight b6 you're forced to play a5 and i
have knight c4 and if i manage to
exchange those two pawns the uh a5 for
a7 then this is just an easy way yeah
this is very easy actually with g7 and
h5 uh against the bishop it's not it's
not even it's not even close
so knights he had a strange move but i
think as long as he found one of the two
he's winning easy win here for raja
opening up the tournament as we
mentioned and also opening up the
tournament is this game between elsa
maria de body and chris robcat though
uh you know elsian hasn't had the best
technique in this tournament he actually
retreated the knight to e2 we left it
over here
i was thinking he was going to play
knight h5
hit this queen he might have been a
little bit scared about the move queen
g6
but i was eyeing this check and i felt
like the check was annoying enough
that something would fall although maybe
i'm being optimistic although maybe i'm
not being optimistic you have to go to
f8 let me explain why
if you go to
g8 i have the move rook takes e6 that's
a very simple distraction this is not
checkmate uh this is not checkmate
because the queen is defending
and if you take on e6
then i have queen g7 mate so you have to
go to f8 probably this is the only
realistic alternative
and now we start to calculate and now
it's time to calculate i was hoping that
it would be kind of easy but let's go
rook takes e6 yeah rookie six might just
pick up material right let's go queen g
back here check
here check
here check
another thing is this finishes the game
this finishes the game because if the
king goes to the b file doesn't really
matter where i go check and takes
if you go to d8 i go check and takes and
if you go to c6 i also go check and
takes
and this is easy
just not that hard yeah
stress is easy something just is easy so
that's uh the two extra points in a
queen end game where you have a passport
on the a3 side and there's a zero
percent chance you're going to get
perpetual so is there a way to find some
sort of uh stalemate in the position
probably not probably not no way yeah i
mean i'm taking the rook
yeah that this this would have finished
the game so unfortunately the body
sometimes does this he doesn't actually
sit down and calculate and finish the
game off and it's an important part of
technique because although he did spend
a lot of time on this decision
he spent maybe 10 15 minutes it all
looks very straightforward am i missing
something knight h5
this queen maybe king to e7 oh sorry so
queen to e7 let's go quickly yeah but i
don't calculate this right i don't care
about this move because the queen
doesn't
generate a threat right and you're not
running on g2 like knight is just a nice
attacking piece i can choose whatever i
wanted here queen c3 or queen f3 or
whatever so from a practical perspective
you're just saying that
quinto g6 has to be the most concrete
and the only one that you should
calculate right it's the only one that
presents a challenge yeah you know
otherwise you go knight h5 and on
queenie's heart and just figure it out
next move all right let's see big big c
and and to be even more precise yeah i
think the move queen c3 actually just
finishes the game but it doesn't matter
the queen 26 is the only move
queen b7 you got queen b7 the king has
to go to f8 for reasons are already
explained
i know yeah that looks like the other ah
okay okay okay so you can give a check
first
king to f8 rook to c6 and now i go to d1
first ah and then you go rugby one and
the rook is hiding somewhere maybe right
as we are being told sam savion won his
game against uh aramaic piano big one
for the standings
check here
check here i think this is what he was
spending most of his and probably he
spent most of his time here right
because even when you get here
i'm not really sure i'm gonna pick up
this rook
in so many lines it looks winning
but from afar i wouldn't be able to
guarantee it the way i was guaranteeing
the other positions yeah still a lot of
work to be done but i do expect elshan
to to finish it off eventually
uh let me just really quickly take a
look at the ray robson game and then we
can take a look at what's happened so
far today i have no idea what's going on
here
i uh they've been repeating moves so
yeah but you know that ray loves
repeating moves just to gain time
uh so you could start to gain too much
ray robson repeats moves to gain time
but spends 10 minutes doing the
three-fold repetition all right let's
take a look at what's happened uh so far
today with uh group a
well we have uh two games that have a
finish that is the victory of alex
landerman over camille dragoon and the
draw between hans niemann and jeffrey
shang were expecting a uh win by samsung
actually
has won his game ilya nishnik against
michonne tipoff and ray robson against
this virg are still very tense battles
probably going to be finishing in uh
draw both games and how about the b
group yeah the big grip is the one where
we expect five decisive games if i
despite the fact that we only have
two results up there
all three of the remaining games are so
heavily on to one side that we don't
expect them to slip it up christopher
you is currently losing against raja
harshit
robert hungaski is currently totally
winning against tito stromovicius after
the lithuanian player blundered a full
piece
and el shannemoriadiabati is currently
in the driver's seat more than that i
would say against chris rapka which is a
huge result for the big group especially
paired up with that game in which
abimanyam mishra with the black pieces
defeated arman mikhailian as they would
be the players tied for first place
going into seventh round well alejandro
this is it for us today the abbreviated
show of the spring chess classic don't
forget we will be back tomorrow with
round number seven at the same time same
place on twitch or on youtube depending
on where you are watching 3 30 p.m
central time 1 p.m is when the game
started start and we'll see you tomorrow
we'll see you tomorrow there's still
three more rounds of chess after today
join us for that and we'll see you there
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the st louis
chess club is prohibited
you